the questions keep on mounting but 20
days on one has remained the same what
happened to Nicola bully we now know
this was a mum of two vulnerable with
ongoing struggles
as soon as she was reported missing
following the information that was
provided to the police by her partner
Paul
and based on a number of specific
vulnerabilities that we were made aware
of Nicola was graded as high risk but
what was it about Nicola that raised
alarms something police today couldn't
answer
can you just give us a bit more
information about what Nikki's partner
told you about her vulnerabilities I'm
not going to go into the details of
those individual vulnerabilities I've
asked you to respect the family who are
going through unimaginable pain and
distress at this moment
but those vulnerabilities based are
decision making in terms of grading
Nicola as high risk and have continued
to form part of my investigation
throughout it was however a revelation
too important to dismiss Lancashire
police hours after this news conference
revealed what those specific
vulnerabilities were
Nicola had in the past suffered with
some significant issues with alcohol
they said which were brought on by her
ongoing struggles with the menopause and
these struggles had resurfaced over
recent months this has caused some real
challenges for Paul and the family
just 17 days before Nicola disappeared
police and health professionals were
called to her family home they attended
a report for a concern of welfare no one
at the time was arrested but it's being
investigated
how the 45 year old mum of two was
feeling and what she was thinking on
that Friday morning is now a prominent
line of inquiry
after almost three weeks of extensive
searching and a major police operation
investigators have theories but not many
answers it's the 20th day since Nicola
has been missing how confident are you
and your team that you'll find Nicola
bully alive I hope with all my heart
that we find the club bully alive more
than anything how confident are you
I have told you that my working
hypothesis is at the moment through all
the information that we have gathered
that the likelihood is that Nicola
has unfortunately gone in the river
finding Nicola is everyone's priority
here it's a wonder how hope hasn't faded
almost three weeks on details of the
troubles she faced will be no barrier
into man Rasheed Sky News Lancashire